for women's leadership development not
just in las vegas but nationally and it
is back for its 15th year joining us to
tell us more is founding president and
ceo for the foundation for women's
empowerment and leadership phyllis a
james welcome
thank you thank you for having me 15
years first of all congratulations on
that thank you that is quite an
accomplishment but tell us about the
women's leadership conference i've been
a couple of times and it it truly is
transformative and life-changing tell us
a little bit about it well it's a
conference for
all aspiring women and men
who are seeking to develop themselves
personally and professionally
to however they define
their next level and so we want
everybody to reach their full potential
in life and whatever we can do at our
conference to help facilitate that
that's what we're trying to do and i'm
glad that you said that it is for women
and men because i did see quite a few
men there and it you know it was just it
was really great to see uh a lot of the
men
really uplifting and
supporting women you know right well you
know our workplaces
our communities our society are composed
of women and men
and
in order to reach true gender equity in
my opinion
women cannot take the entire brunt of
the effort men have to be a part of it
absolutely what about some of the
speakers that's one thing i always look
forward to at the women's leadership
conference they you have incredible
speakers who's coming this year
well every year we strive to have
powerful women role models
who
symbolize achievement and courage and
triumph so this year
we're going to have hall of fa
famed speaker marilyn sherman who will
talk about
achieving success in the front row
and
not sitting in the back cheap seats oh
and selling yourself short and we're
also going to have a nationally
acclaimed
syndicated columnist michelle singletary
from the washington post she's going to
talk about how to rebuild yourself
financially after the struggles of the
pandemic
we're going to have a neuroscientist
who is a pioneer of mental health and
wellness in the workplace her name is dr
romy mooshtock
and finally we're going to have a
nationally acclaimed
journalist
who is actually an immigrant from
venezuela her name is mariana atencio oh
it's going to be so great so many
conferences workshops and you definitely
want to be a part of it the 15th annual
women's leadership conference
august 7th and 8th from 9 am to 5 pm at
the mgm grand conference center it is
so worth it i hope to see